in the future self-driving cars will be
safer and more reliable than humans
but for this to happen we need
technologies that allow cars to respond
faster than humans we need algorithms
that can drive better than humans and we
need cameras that can see more than
humans can see for example imagine a
self-driving car is about to make a
blind turn and there's an oncoming car
or perhaps there's a child about to run
into the street
fortunately our future car will have
this superpower a camera that can see
around corners to detect these potential
hazards for the past few years as a PhD
student in the Stanford computational
imaging lab I've been working on a
camera that can do just this a camera
kit that can image objects hidden around
corners or blocked from direct
line-of-sight so let me give you an
example of what our camera can see this
is an outdoor experiment we conducted
where our camera system is scanning the
side of this building with the laser and
the scene that we want to capture is
hidden around the corner behind this
curtain so our camera system can't
actually see it directly and yet somehow
our camera can still capture the 3d
geometry of the scene so how do we do
this the magic happens here in this
camera system you can think of this as a
type of high-speed camera not one that
operates at a thousand frames per second
or even a million frames per second but
a trillion frames per second so fast
that it can actually capture the
movement of light itself and to give you
an example of just how fast light
travels let's compare it to the speed of
a fast running comic book superhero who
can move it up to three times the speed
of sound it takes a pulse of light about
3.3 billions of a second or 3.3
nanoseconds to travel the distance of a
meter
well in that same time our superhero has
moved
less than the width of a human hair
that's pretty fast but actually we need
to image much faster if we want to
capture light moving at sub centimeter
scales so our camera system can capture
photons at time frames of just 50
trillionth of a second or 50 Pico
seconds so we take this ultra-high speed
camera and we pair it with a laser that
sends out short pulses of light each
pulse travels to this visible wall and
some light scatters back to our camera
but we also use the wall to scatter
light around the corner to the hidden
object and back we repeat this
measurement many times to capture the
arrival times of many photons from
different locations on the wall and
after we capture these measurements we
can create a trillion frame per second
video of the wall well this wall may
look ordinary to our own eyes at a
trillion frames per second we can see
something truly incredible we can
actually see waves of light scattered
back from the hidden scene and splashing
against the wall and each of these waves
carries information about the hidden
object that sent it so we can take these
measurements and pass them into a
reconstruction algorithm to then recover
the 3d geometry of this hidden scene now
I want to show you one more example of
an indoor scene that we captured this
time with a variety of different hidden
objects and these objects have different
appearances so they reflect light
differently for example this glossy
dragon statue reflects light differently
than the mirrored disco ball or the
white discus thrower statue and we can
actually see the differences in the
reflected light by visualizing it as
this 3d volume where we've just taken
the video frames and stacked them
together and time here is represented as
the depth dimension of this cube these
bright dots that you see are reflections
of light from each of the mirrored
facets of the disco ball scattering
against the wall over time the bright
streaks of light that you see arriving
soonest in time are from the glossy
dragon statue that's closest to the wall
and the other streaks of light come from
reflections of light from the book
and from the statue now we can also
visualize these measurements frame by
frame as a video to directly see the
scattered light and again here we see
first reflections of light from the
dragon closest to the wall followed by
bright dots from the disco ball and
other reflections from the bookcase and
finally we see the reflected waves of
light from the statue these waves of
light illuminating the wall are like
fireworks that last for just trillions
of a second and even though these
objects reflect light differently
we can still reconstruct their shapes
and this is what you can see from around
the corner now I want to show you one
more example that's slightly different
in this video you see me dressed in this
reflective suit and our camera system is
scanning the wall at a rate of four
times every second the suit is
reflective so we can actually capture
enough photons that we can see where I
am and what I'm doing without the camera
actually directly imaging me by
capturing photons that scatter from the
wall to my tracksuit back to the wall
and back to the camera we can capture
this indirect video in real time and we
think that this type of practical
non-line of sight imaging could be
useful for applications including for
self-driving cars but also for
biomedical imaging where we need to see
into the tiny structures of the body and
perhaps we could also put similar camera
systems on the robots that we send to
explore other planets now you may have
heard about seeing around corners before
but what I showed you today would have
been impossible just two years ago for
example we can now image large room
sized hidden scenes outdoors and at
real-time rates and we've made
significant advancements towards making
this a practical technology that you
could actually see on a car someday but
of course there's still challenges
remaining for example can we image
hidden scenes at long distances where
we're collecting very very few photons
with lasers that are low power and that
our eye safe
or can we create images from photons
that have scattered around many more
times than just a single bounce around
the corner can we take our prototype
system that's well currently large and
bulky and miniaturize it into something
that can be useful for biomedical
imaging or perhaps a sort of improved
home security system or can we take this
new imaging modality and use it for
other applications I think it's an
exciting new technology and there could
be other things that we haven't thought
of yet to use it for and so well a
future with self-driving cars may seem
distant to us now we're already
developing the technologies that could
make cars safer and more intelligent and
with the rapid pace of scientific
discovery and innovation you never know
what new and exciting capabilities could
be just around the corner
[Applause]